new research offers clues about preterm
births which are defined as birth before
37 weeks a study in the New England
Journal of Medicine identified for the
very first time six key genes linked to
babies born before full-term almost 10%
of babies in this country are born
prematurely think about that number for
just a second and it's the leading cause
of death in children under the age of
five or dr. David agus is here with how
this discovery could lead to healthier
babies all around good morning to you
number one it's good to have you at the
table it's like your real boy we can
touch you in person I'm a real boy oh
boy yeah that's from Pinocchio
okay I know you know that okay this is
big news this is great news it is
enormous I mean you know ten percent of
babies in the United States born preterm
and preterm babies obviously risk of
death but many other issues going on in
life and for now we can identify who's
going to be preterm we can tell you
listen you can't give birth at home or
you can't give birth in a community
house but you don't have to go to a
place with an ICU and now that we know
these genes one of the genes is evolved
in selenium regulation and multivitamins
for example prenatal vitamins don't have
selenium in them so all of a sudden
could lead to major changes but how are
you able to identify the genes that's
also a very big very interesting story
so the answer really is heroes is that
women said take my genetic information
and so these were women predominantly
from 23andme tests who said listen take
my information and learn from it I want
to be part of the solution not the
problem and so they stepped up over
50,000 women and looked at these genes
and they correlated it to when the child
was born and six genes now associated
with preterm birth are out there
David when I saw this story pop last
night online I immediately clicked on it
because I'm interested too as is gene
therapy essentially the future of
Medicine I think targeting genes in this
case is probably rather than correcting
genes but yes is that right now all of a
sudden we have the rosetta stone - all
of us and so instead of
one-size-fits-all instead of waiting and
say oh my gosh I'm a preterm labor let
me rush to the hospital we're gonna know
in advance what's going to happen and so
knowledge is key
in fact gene therapy is a significant
part of the frontier of medicine is it
not no question gene therapy in terms of
cancer and other diseases is going to be
big and important it's very hard to do
gene therapy and change all the genes in
the body it's easier to change one
particular cell type and so in order to
change a whole body it's going to be
difficult but in this case knowing that
one of them is a uterine protein for
example that we may be able to alter to
allow a woman to go to full-term can
radically change maternal in the in
Natal health thanks dad a really
important information thank you David
you have here